we were filming on the budget we were
filming it would be compared to like a
low budget Indie now and we were filming
at a at an accelerated pace
and then the emotions were running so
high
so we would we had no other choices but
to well I know for me and maybe it's
because I'm not nearly as good as an
actor as all the other people I had no
other choice but to exist as that
character all the time
because of the schedule
wow so and Juice was like a really
[ __ ] up character so I was kind of
[ __ ] up for like eight years
really it messed you up for eight years
you were just kind of like not quite
yourself
I tried to turn it off but it was like
we were always all together so our
Dynamic was shaped from the show
wow so it was like you were you were
emulsified into who you were so it was
like you you almost had to take it on
because it was so
all the time all the time you were
always reminded like all the time right
you have a especially when you have a
mohawk and tattoos on your head like you
can't you're that guy get away from it
you can't get away from it which is an
amazing thing
and it really I think like Charlie and I
said the other day I don't think you can
ever do that again it was like a it was
like a moment in time right it doesn't
exist anymore it's like The Sopranos I
talked to those guys and they had a lot
of the same exact kind of deal where
they were just together all the time to
go to dinners all the time and their
characters kind of acted like their
characters
do you still talk to all the guys all of
them all the time all the time just what
a Brotherhood that's crazy you just got
off with Kim I just got off with coats
uh I was taxing with Pearlman I love
them
it was like um
it's like we went now we can reflect on
it
like now but it was like we went through
this thing that we were all unsure of at
the end and we just needed to get away
from each other
and then we came back around I think
that happens I think that happened even
with me and my co-star Tom uh yeah we
were we were you know we were really
cool but the last thing you want to do
is hang with people that you're on set
with all day for all those years and
then a couple years passed and then it
just sort of a friendship evolved you
know kind of respect and respect a
mutual respect it was really weird and
like we we do things together we you
know it's it's nice